Це один із найбільших полісів,
який охоплює територію від Очакова до Миколаєва.
Тобто берегом це близько 90 кілометрів.
Сільські поселення, які належали
юрисдикції Ольвівського полісу.
Й острів Березань — найперше поселення
в Північному Причорномор'ї, звідки і зародилась Ольвія.
Я місцевий житель, виріс тут, знаю тут кожен камінчик.
Я за освітою — історик.
Працював вчителем історії, зараз виконую
обов'язки директора, є науковим співробітником.
Це місце улюблене.
Дуже гордий, що я тут і працюю зараз,
тому що це візитівка села, району й області.
Не кожна область може похизуватися,
що частинка Греції є на її території.
Досить таки визначна частинка Грецїі.
Тут зародилося життя в античному місці,
тут воно, як стверджують вчені, і завершилося.
В 6 ст. до н.е. на цій території
спорудили перші землянки.
І в 4 ст. н. е.  на цьому місці
жили вже останні мешканці Ольвії,
які поступово залишали свої будинки
і виїзджали із цієї місцевості.
Майже кожен клаптик цієї землі — забудований.
Навіть оці круті схили.
Ви можете тут бачити великі стіни,
зокрема із східної сторони,
які саме виконували роль
утримувачів цих будинків,
тому що рівень моря піднімався,
відповідно рівень лиману теж.
Територія почала підтоплюватись,
відповідно — земля почала йти в річку.
До 500 метрів Ольвії зараз під водою.
В 1970-х – на початку 2000-х років проводилось
декілька підводних експедицій.
Підводні роботи ускладнені тут.
По-перше, тим, що великий шар
мулистих відкладень, постійна течія.
Складно працювати.
Але під водою все ж таки
були знайдені ряд об'єктів.
Залишки порту Ольвійського, склади припортові,
в яких було знайдено десятки амфор.
Частина оборонної стіни,
яка на той час ще була на суші
і поступово почала затоплюватись.
Антична Ольвія була досить
розвиненим містом.
Була система водопроводу
з накопичувальними колодязями
і система каналізації з відводом
каналізаційних стоків за межі міста,
де були зроблені спеціальні колодязі
для зберігання відходів,
які наповнювались, засипались —
облаштовувались нові.
Для античності це досить таки
прогресивна частина саме в структурі міста.
Ольвійські будинки мали не дуже великі стіни,
так само, як і підвальні приміщення —
знаючи велич римських будівель.
Саме це і простежується в Ольвії.
Тобто товсті стіни, можна уявити високі будівлі.
І вся ця територія була обнесена
ще й додатковою оборонною стіною.
Тривалий час Рим відігравав дуже позитивну роль
в збереженні Ольвії і в неможливості її знищення,
але коли вже в 3 ст. н. е.
римський легіон залишив цю територію,
тому що у Рима почалися проблеми
на зовнішній політиці,
то Ольвія стала доступна
для всіх варварських племен.
Будинки, економіка, культура, побут
тут уже не були відновлені,
і Ольвія просто напросто занепала
і жителі її покинули.
Праворуч від мене храм Зевса,
ліворуч — залишки храму
Аполлона Дельфінія, покровителя Ольвії.
Скоріш за все, храми були розібрані
самими жителями
під час одного із набігів кочових племен задля того,
аби вони не осквернили священні місця.
На жаль, храмів не збереглося.
Є лише залишки фундаментів,
за якими була зроблена невеличка
реконструкція планування цих споруд.
Звичайно, що в планах в нас
є макетування цієї ділянки,
створення в реальному розмірі
із сучасного матеріалу — сучасного каменю,
хоча б приблизного вигляду цих храмів.
Я думаю, що в найближчі п'ять років,
якщо буде фінансування і підтримка,
можливо, частину Ольвії ми все ж таки тут відтворимо,
можливо, люди зацікавляться:
подивитися не лише на залишки фундаментів,
а й на відновлені храми та будинки.
На жаль, дуже багато людей, які приїжджають сюди,
вперше взагалі чують про це місце.
Ми докладаємо всіх зусиль,
які можливі на сучасному етапі,
щоб цей об'єкт популяризувати не лише як наукову,
а як туристичну й історичну пам'ятку.
Ми все ж таки чекаємо,
що знову до нас буде приїздити консул Греції.
Раніше майже щороку
новий консул відвідував це місце.
Екскурсанти безпосередньо
із Греції до нас приїздили.
Ми були дуже здивовані,
що вони ледь не цілували тут каміння.
Настільки люди ставляться
до своєї історії, до своєї культури,
що ми були, чесно, здивовані.
Щороку влітку тут організовується
вже третій рік поспіль міжнародна,
до цього виключно Ольвійська,
українська експедиція.
Починаючи з 2016 року в Ольвії працює
велика група археологів з Польщі та Німеччини.
Цікаво, і позитивно, і перспективно —
вся ця робота.
Сподіваємося, що Ольвія
на європейському рівні
також коли-небудь засвітиться
і займе своє місце.